you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprised
deleted scene for Batman vs Superman I
hadn't even planned to make a video but
they drop the super big easter egg for
Darkseid the new gods mother boxes
there's even a little bit of Brainiac in
there too I don't really consider this
spoilery for the movie because it didn't
make it into the movie but I will say
just careful for spoilers just to be
safe so assuming you've seen the movie
and you know what a mother box is that's
pretty much what this looks like in this
universe the DC movie universe if you
remember all the Justice League short
scenes where we see the cyborg getting
his pout like he gets activated by a
mother box when it interfaces with him
but what's going on here is that this
clip is called communion Lex Luthor is
communing with the AI of the ship
learning about the new gods and learning
about mother boxes when you think about
it it's really not that big of a
surprise because Batman had the vision
of Darkseid's Omega symbol so we knew
there was going to be new gods in
Justice League part 1 in part 2 we just
didn't know what it was gonna look like
most people want to believe this is
Steppenwolf he is one of Darkseid's
high-ranking generals but I actually
think there's a good chance that this
could be Darkseid's father Yuga Khan now
when most people think of Darkseid they
think of apocalypse and vice versa
but before Darkseid became ruler of
apocalypse his father Yuga Khan was
ruler of apocalypse Darkseid was born of
a family he had a mother and a father
Yuga Khan Integra he also had a brother
very similar to what ended up happening
later with Thanos and his family on
Titan he also had a brother named eros
so Darkseid came first so you can credit
a lot of the inspiration for Thanos and
his family to Jack Kirby in the fourth
world jim Starlin created Thanos but
before that Jack Kirby created the new
gods if you are a big fan of comic book
history there's a really fascinating
story about how Jack Kirby came up with
the idea for the new gods when he was
still at Marvel working on the Thor
title he wanted to kill a bunch of the
Thor characters and usher in the new
gods but there was some contractual
problems so he went to DC and he took
his fourth world characters with him so
the new gods became DC characters but
then later jim Starlin came along and
kind of did his version of those
characters but it gets a little
confusing when you talk about the origin
of Darkseid how he became the ruler of
apocalypse he has a real name his name
is
we don't really know how the movie is
going to be using the New Gods
specifically we just know we're gonna
see a version of Darkseid I don't I
don't think that this is Darkseid but I
do expect him to look a little bit
different than he does in the comics
Zack Snyder has this very particular
color palette and just to be clear when
Lex Luthor is watching this this kind of
interactive presentation it's just like
when Superman was learning from his
father about his Kryptonian history like
this is what happened to our planet this
is the rise and fall of the Kryptonian
Empire they had that Art Deco 3d
etch-a-sketch thing going on so that's
kind of what's going on here in the
birthing chamber Lex Luthor learning
from the AI of the ship about the new
gods and mother boxes that actually add
some context to the end of the movie
when Lex Luthor is saying the Bell has
been rung it can't be unrung it goes to
the shot of that painting and you
remember the speech about the devil
coming from the sky
thus they Herald the arrival of the new
gods so Lex Luthor actually it sounds
like he knows a lot more than the movie
let on but the other really small Easter
egg here is just Brainiac related when
the people put their sniper scopes on
the back of his head it just forms the
Brainiac symbol upside down it's just a
little Easter egg I think that Brainiac
is gonna flow from all this - but just
taking it as its presented it's really
just new gods stuff
Brainiac is kind of a separate thing so
I think the movies gonna introduce him
in a slightly different way he's not
gonna arrive via boomtube with all the
other new gods some of you are asking
what the hell is a mother box why is it
so important you may have seen versions
of them in the comics or in the cartoons
what it is is like a sentient
supercomputer that is capable of
accessing the source now when you talk
about the source that's what Jack Kirby
in in his fourth world comics presents
as the sword like the literal source of
everyone's special powers there is even
a thing that Jack Kirby called the
source wall that borders the multiverse
imagine there being an actual physical
wall around the entire universe that is
the source wall so I know a lot of you
are thinking hey doesn't this sound a
lot like the tesseract from the Marvel
Universe yeah it's kind of the same
thing they have almost a limitless
supply of power but because they're
sentient just like the tesseract is
sentient they also have different uses
but most often they're used for instant
teleportation across the universe so
yeah it does sound like a lot like a
tesseract
but remember
Jack Kirby did all this first so
technically if someone's getting ripped
off here
DC is getting ripped off by Marvel but
whatever you get the idea mother boxes
sentient supercomputers that have a lot
of different uses
most often transportation now you kind
of understand how cyborg getting fused
with the mother box turns him into a
living computer sentient supercomputer
fuses with advanced cyborg technology so
when we get to cyborg you really find
out some of the cool stuff that mother
boxes can do that a lot of that will
probably be explained in justice league
because that's how Darkseid will get to
earth let me know in the comments though
who do you think this is do you think
this is actually Steppenwolf do you
think this is a version of Darkseid I
actually I don't think that's the case
or do you think that this might be
Darkseid's father Yuga Khan who actually
doesn't really show up that often when
Darkseid's around most stories about
Darkseid just focus on Darkseid
like if you haven't been reading it you
have to start checking out Darkseid Wars
if Jones is doing some really cool stuff
and it's not gonna be affected by all
the rebirth stuff that's going on that's
all separate so what's gonna happen
tonight is the big WTF is the flash is
going to cross over to Supergirl cross
through the multiverse she's on a
different earth so that's gonna be a
pretty big deal just by itself I'll be
posting a video for it after it airs
there are a couple things that I'm
behind on just because of all the Batman
V Superman craziness that's going on so
I'll try to catch up with that over the
next couple of days though there'll be
new flash new agents of shield new arrow
and I think that's about it for TV there
was an awesome trailer for Jonah Hex on
legends of tomorrow and Talia al Ghul so
I'll try to get to that later if I have
some time the crazy thing is we haven't
even gotten to Captain America Civil War
stuff that'll start ramping up really
quickly too but while you guys wait for
my flash video to post tonight you can
click here for all my Batman V Superman
Easter eggs and you can click here to
learn about the end of the movie and
what Zack Snyder has said about Justice
League thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight